how should the US government and the
rest of us respond to the coronavirus
which has just been declared a global
pandemic by the World Health
Organization Balaji's here navasana who
was on the short list ahead of Donald
Trump's Food and Drug Administration has
some strong opinions
he's a former venture capitalist at
Andreessen Horowitz and he's a serial
entrepreneur with a PhD in electrical
engineering the genetic testing company
he co-founded council help change the
way millions of people prepare for
Parenthood and his cryptocurrency
startup earned com was acquired by coin
base where he served as chief technology
officer in a prescient lively and
constantly updated Twitter feed serie
navasana has been way ahead of the curve
in noting the coronaviruses spread and
potential to cause a global public
health crisis and a massive economic and
social disruption to life as we know it
Bellagio thanks for talking hello
let's let's get right to it you were
really early in sounding the alarm about
Corona fires how did you hear about it
and why were you on top of it and what
does that say about Silicon Valley
versus journalists on the East Coast
sure following you know the corona virus
out of my peripheral vision is kind of
one of many stories until I saw the
lockdown on January 23rd and that was
unprecedented it was an unthinkable
signal you know the Chinese government
is completely focused on economic
development
so to quarantine millions of people
which would soon become hundreds of
moans of people that made me pay
attention to what was going on and so I
began talking to many friends of mine
Chinese engineers entrepreneurs angels
at the lake and the qualitative picture
that I got from this was his hair raised
right you know we're talking videos and
photos of people of being blockaded in
their apartments dying on the street
even one of a man throwing himself off a
bridge because he couldn't get to the
hospital even want to bring the virus
home to family I didn't know what to
believe from this you know something
that could be the-- but other in those
images would seem fairly difficult to
fake even with these technology and they
seem to match the general circumstances
so you
even if some of them are true these were
sort of sci-fi movie level events
happening in China right and if I you
know was too skeptical uh you know I
remind myself that there was an
officially acknowledged scale to lock
temperatures unprecedent and that was an
independent reference point of ground
truth that one could could anchor on
right now you know I also have a
background in like bioinformatics
molecular diagnostics genomics and so on
so you know even though maybe a lot of
people know me for crypto and venture
capital actually I did many years as the
founder of the genomic testing company
prior to getting into crypto and angel
and venture and and I was an academic
for many years so so the third thing I
did is you know I dug into the
literature and read all these sort of
dispassionate medical reports and these
these kinds of articles in the regional
medicine with Lancet they're written in
a style which is almost like the
opposite of clicking so like you know
the first the first u.s. case study
written up in eighty Jim said something
like you know thirty-five year old
patient with no pre-existing conditions
contracted bilateral pneumonia at by
d-10 we pursued compassionate use and in
English that means a healthy 35 year old
man was brought to death's door and
meaning the experimental drug to save
his life
okay now I mean zero insult whatsoever
towards of folks writing these articles
everyone acceptance style but when you
translate them it's eyebrow-raising
you know basically you know here's a
healthy thirty five-year-old about to
die and took 10 days and the team and an
experimental drug to see them um and
that was like the first case in the USA
right and that that's a contagious
disease so you know you start mapping
that not just one person but we put two
ten people or a hundred people or a
thousand people that sort skate very
expensive in all senses of the term in
terms of you know suffering and in terms
of medical resources inside so the
combination of a China's official state
action be unofficial social media put
some people in china and see articles in
biomedical journals that's what maybe
triangulate on this early is something
to potentially critical importance so
what what were journalists missing or
and actually for that matter what were
what were american health officials
because the new
times ran a story this morning about how
Seattle there were a couple people in
Seattle who said look there's something
really big going on here and then they
they couldn't really get traction within
their own health organizations but what
what were journalists and health
officials missing so I want to say you
know first you know some professional
journalists really got this right and
you know I've got like a piece coming on
you know what's called corporate
journalism versus citizen journalism and
not all corporate journalism is bad for
example on journalists that epic I seen
in China they published really
impressive stories in the face of state
censorship and you know the New York
Times they're China reporters you know
like Emma Quinn and pole Moser they did
pretty impressive work there's people on
the ground in China who this
consequences from both the government
and the buyers to get the story out so I
want to run kind of level set that way
but I'd say tech journalists completely
failed on the most important story of
the year so far if not the decade you
know this could be you know to the 2020s
what 9/11 was to the 2000s or the
financial crisis to the 2010s you know
kind of the starting gun that kicks off
so you're telling me were we're in a new
decade and it's already kind of at the
[ __ ]
I'm not saying in the shiver but
certainly this is going to be an event
that colors this decade you know the the
level of the number of consequences
obviously politically like for
technology for biotech for all kinds of
things for immigration policy you know
so just focusing you know for a second
just on the tech hangul right tech
journalists completely failed on this
and it's not just that infamous recode
article talking about how terrible I
mean handshake stamp pretty much every
every intelligence politician in the
world is doing or the BuzzFeed article
saying don't worry about you know
coronavirus worry about the flu he was
the tone of these journalists and all
their tweets and whatnot talking about
the terrified racist xenophobic
bubble-boy VCS who were scared to death
of this total non-issue of bias right
and and that's all a matter of public
record and of course this non-issue
turned out to be very much an issue
they weren't simply getting the story
wrong but they were actively attempting
to shame and silence people getting the
story right and some of them you know
later in sincerely apologized others
wrote you know columns about how they
got the story wrong and the slightly
more insincerely and then once Trump
started adopting their early talking
points about how the virus was just the
flu several of them have reversed
themselves and pretended you know
they've been taking it seriously all
along you know they were they were
against a virus you know before they
were for or against for right um but but
as a group I think Tech Journal is
completely just just unforgettably
failed on the virus crisis and the way I
know people at least within tech will
never forget what what explains that or
our tech journalists and you know and
and we're gonna get to the kind of
libertarian intersection or are they are
they always skeptical about you know the
great big thing or is it particularly I
mean because in a way tech journalists
seem to be suckers for certain types of
stories and then they reject others what
would what would make them more prone to
rejecting this story there's technical
big things there
they're credulous of big things that are
negative you know against the tech
companies and they are skeptical of
things that are positive right on and
and the reason for it I think it really
boils down to the fact that you know
another word for a lot of journalists is
they are employees of a media
corporation and those media corporations
are direct competitors of tech
corporations and their direct
competitors
certainly monetarily on the back end in
terms of advertisers and what-have-you
but even more importantly on the front
end in terms of influence right you know
in many different ways people seek
information on Google they talk to each
other on Facebook and whatsapp they post
on Twitter in many many different ways
that undermines kind of information
monopoly and you know the
counter-argument often get is oh there's
an advertising versus editorial wall and
journalism tech people don't understand
this and of course you know that
actually exists within tech companies as
well you know Google has a wall between
search engine engineers and advertising
engineers that that that wall at least
existed for many years but the real
it is true that journalists aren't you
know day-to-day ad sales but they are
hyper conscious in the fact that the
industry is generally declining that
fellow journalists have gotten laid off
and that these you know callow tech
people seem to be old making millions of
dollars of course they focus on the
successes going on right so I think
certainly part of it is the fact that
many of these tech journalists
frequently lack technical backgrounds I
mean there's this amusing thing where
folks were like oh ha ha
all these VC is commenting on the
colonel bars and you know I had to [ __ ]
my head because many pcs have biotech
backgrounds that's like if not half of
DC it's a very large chunk of DC
founders fund Y Combinator a six in Z
all have large biotech funds and biotech
in the broad sense meaning by the
minutes is not simply recombinant DNA um
so so you know and then of course
there's lots of specialist biotech funds
uh but but tech journalists they lack
technical backgrounds they often you
know they can't code they don't know
drugs Diagnostics therapeutics but they
comment and so it's really part of it is
a lack of technical background I think
another part of it is um you know as you
may be aware many of these tech
journalists they they actually grew up
rich they went to private school their
trust funds or inherited wealth and
they're motivated by bizarre sort of
animus against the nouveau riche tech
people and one way of parsing is really
old money versus new money and you know
there's a guy Antonio Garcia Martinez
who tweeting about this you know
recently and a bunch of ruthlessly all
of them and then many of them
volunteered
one of the volunteered that she had gone
to a $90,000 a year private school run
you know before anybody so real that
real that back for a sec you know and
how does that map on to missing the
coronavirus story great question is
basically the combination of a technical
ignorance and B class hostility curled
into a cocktail where they didn't know
what they didn't know about the virus
but they didn't know that they hated
these tech interlopers and that's what
drove ecology
okay so discuss how is coronavirus
different than the flu you don't wanted
that one of the early stories was you
know and I and I think there's a
plausibility factor that that this is a
type of flu might be a little bit worse
but you know let's let's not lose our it
over this
yeah so let me give a qualitative answer
and then a quantity so on this first
move on was an orange time okay I mean
that it's promised but is normalcy okay
um less than sixty days later seven
hospitals in Wuhan were filled
according to Kaizen um the sick were
being sent home to die
China instituted the largest quarantine
in recorded history and basically
wartime measures were instituted now
that is not a bad flu season you know
that that is something that is on a
completely different level and you know
you you have to think okay well you know
the Chinese government the Chinese
people these they're there's many
criticisms one can give them but there's
serious people you know these are not
folks who are known for doing anything
like this they're so focused on economic
growth right so that right there is a
pretty unthinkable signal and then let
you know I tweeted that and now later
Iran and Italy have both had very
similar kind of scenario so so this fire
seems to be overwhelming hospital
systems flooding them you know with with
folks with respiratory failure crashing
hospital systems so that itself is
something which is qualitative now the
quantitative is when people are
comparing this to the fluid they're
comparing a constant to a variable the
flu is a known quantity it's roughly 60
we know within bounds how many people
it's going to infect a bad flu season
does not crash a hospital right um
whereas this is something which is
wildly contagious has at least on the
order of 10 X the laval debris it has
far higher hospitalization rate than the
flu and you know better way of calling
you get like an aggressive viral
pneumonia right because people know the
word pneumonia and they note pneumonia
is actually serious right so what is
what is your best guess of you know the
lethality of this what is it gonna be
you know where we gonna have a 1% kind
of death rate out of infection overall
what compared to a tenth of a percent
for the flu or does it does it make
sense to talk about in these terms yet
alright so good question let me let me
say first is the the so called case
fatality rate which
is the percentage of folks who die from
disease would be diagnosed with it he
varies a lot between countries Italy is
now reporting like 8% okay now why are
you why is it so high well Italy it
seems like it's really just killing
folks who are 70 or 80 plus these are
also obviously human beings there are
elders our parents our grandparents or
what have you
um so just bloody just extremely
dangerous they're also extremely
dangerous in the u.s. that nursing home
you know they reported something like
you know last I saw it like 26 people
out of 120 died a normal month it's an
acute care home but in normal month they
said three to seven died so you have 26
died that's your excess of like you know
20 25 deaths right um 2023 deaths so so
but the broader point is let's even say
the case fatality rate is 2% there's
there's a few reasons why that is not
look first of all if 2% of America died
or if um 60% of America got it and then
2 percent of those diet that is millions
of people that is like that was in a 911
right so that alone 2 percent is a very
high number in that sense there's
completely excess unanticipated deaths
Avenue or not number 2 is lots of people
you know again W chose stats you know
have been reported these will vary a lot
but W chose reporting something under of
20% have serious conditions requiring
hospitalization 20% getting hospitalized
not all of those people are going to
bounce back okay for example radiology
paper that I say where you know
prominent radiologists or incredible
people at UCLA USC are biscuit serving
looks ours and MERS there was there's
permanent lung damage there for a
substantial fraction of the folks
affected by that it's not necessarily
case you get Cobb at 19 and you just you
know jump out of bed and you're you're
all set if you don't die um there's a
continuum anything serious enough to put
20% of people in the hospital is gonna
cause permanent damage to people
probably at least to some people like
thing about polio right it didn't kill
everybody right but it did paralyzing
people so so that's the second thing is
you know so first is 2% is actually sold
pretty high death rate per second is
other folks that can be criminally
injured and third is quantity really
matters you know if you had a 2% case
fatality rate
and this thing was not that contagious
it only infected a thousand people yeah
okay it would not be something that
requires the attention of every
government to work but scale matters you
have something that has the potential in
the absence of dramatic intervention to
scale to millions and then maybe
billions of people just to show that
that's possible
remember the swine flu from 2009 mm-hmm
so there's a technique called cero
surveys where you're actually going to
take blood out of somebody's arm it's
not a mathematical model um you know so
there's a paper which went and looked at
a bunch of people who've done serous
surveys in different look difference of
antibodies against h1n1 and they found
that about 10 to 20 percent of people in
like a dozen countries had antibodies to
h1 and said some frequencies for
molecular acid it's not that's on
mathematical modeling but that maybe is
10 to 20 percent of people in the world
have done swine feed
now if you have something like carbon 19
which is potentially as contagious as
swine flu so can gets that scale of
seven hundred million or one point of
people but is far more lethal that's an
extremely dangerous thing so that's why
basically you know three reasons that
you know the fatality breeds actually
it's very years pretty high number one
two percent actually pretty high number
two there's potential for long-term
illness cause people are getting
hospitalized in between the scale is
massive so the sheer number of people
flooding into emergency rooms and
someone will crash hospital systems and
that by the way has second-order
consequences you crash the hospital and
then what happens nobody wants to come
into the hospital why because you don't
wanna get carbon 19 right so all other
routine care goes down right you have an
appendix you need to get there that goes
down you just want to get a check-up
can't do right you want a liver baby all
this stuff so it has second-order
effects on mortality and so in the
population go ahead okay so you make it
you're making the case that this is a
serious issue that really is needs you
know mass attention at different levels
out of the country so far that you
mentioned or the and a couple that we
have it you know there's China there is
a rat Iran and Italy a bit hardest hit
by most accounts it's obviously in the
US and we're going to be seeing numbers
doubling and
no the doubling cube going up a South
Korea has talked about having
effectively contained it it seems or at
least according to some of the reports
coming out of there what countries are
doing well in dealing with this and what
countries are something that we really
need to avoid so it looks like in this
kind of first round that Asian countries
so you know I wasn't sure what to make
of China's posted decline you know like
a week or so ago but now that South
Korea Taiwan and looks like Singapore
Malaysia potentially are getting this
under control it looks like it is
possible to halt the spread through
trying to like measures of lockdown
quarantine of insulin so okay and and by
that and so on and so forth let's
including kind of enforced social
distancing which seems yes a lot begin
it again of just having not only having
people stay out of the workplace they
had a big meeting places but then you
know not getting too close to each other
when they're walking around the street
and I think the other countries that I
think have done reasonably well Soph
Estonia you know not a surprise
competent country Israel I think has
done a pretty good job right so far
right and it generally the countries
that you know like you know Israel
Singapore something these were smart
countries with serious people right I
haven't even looked into buys numbers
but I wouldn't be surprised if they're
Jews so they're also they're you know
they're smart countries with serious
people etc they're also a lot of them
are either very authoritarian or much
more authoritarian than the US including
a country like Israel which you know for
a variety of national security reasons
people they're put up with a much more
invasive day-to-day presence of the
state you're a libertarian I mean you're
one of the kind of libertarian
visionaries for this horrible decade
that has just I started how do you how
do you feel about that kind of stuff or
you know you to be an anarchist or
anything I'm certainly not but you know
how do we know that this is
the time where you say okay you know
what we do have to seed extra control to
the state for a certain period of time
or or is this just the beginning of a
lockdown that really never gets relieved
so I want to in a very polite way you
can test the premise polite by the way
yeah but I would actually not call
myself a libertarian and I think I've
actually been consistent about that over
the years I'm sympathetic to certain
libertarian concepts in our ears but you
know um here's here's my mental model
and I tweeted about this or over I think
the ideal is a competent centralized
government which you can effectively
sign the social contract with the terms
of service by immigrating back so
immigrate to Israel you immigrate to
Singapore and by immigrating there
you're effectively just like you know
you sign up for Facebook you sign up for
Google um there's there's Terms of
Service and if you don't like them you
at least have the back button you can
leave and you don't you're not mandated
to it I know that's not completely ideal
because there's Facebook pixels Google
pixels that will track you across web
it's done
but let's say at a high level you can
make that analogy right you could if you
enter the society here's a kind of
sentence contract if not you know um so
a competent centralized government um
you know for example like you know I
personally would prefer not to own a
firearm I personally prefer a government
that controls crime to an extent that I
can actually trust in that government to
protect my family and property and
what-have-you and I think Singapore is
like that you know now with that said if
the best is a competent centralized
government the worst is a malicious
centralized government like the USSR you
know like like Cuba or North Korea or
have you and then you know not quite as
bad as bad but certainly quite bad is an
incompetent sinful US government has
distinct from actively malicious and of
course there's there's gradations of
that okay now
but like let's say where the US is right
now right um you know at city state and
federal levels
we have not seen phenomenal leadership
on the coronavirus crisis in fact we
haven't seen phenomenal leadership in
quite a while you can argue that you
know the peak of the USA was roughly
bracketed by 1933 in 1968 you know so 19
33 Hoover Dam 1945 Manhattan Project
1968 Apollo that was a period of peak
centralization when the US government
actually got a lot of the technical
talent and was able to build and ship
big things and um before and after that
period you actually have the technical
talent and I'm not saying technical
talent is everything but if it's a lot
you know um you had the technical you
know before that era the quote robber
barons and you know who captains of
industry or building railroads and
aviation the Wright brothers all those
kinds of people then afterwards you have
all the tech CEOs and investors and
hedge fund goes to you know to some
extent and so was my point my point is
while the best is a competent
centralized government and the worst is
and malicious government and the
second-worst
by a big jump it's still bad isn't
incompetence at West Germany in between
a competent and an incompetent
centralized government is the
decentralized response so what are they
yeah what are the what are the best
elements of the decentralized response
and how much of that is coming from
non-governmental agencies so you know
and how important are that yeah let's
talk a little bit about that yes
decentralized response I so certainly
very specifically it's things like the
Gates Foundation working with welcome
and MasterCard to go and Wellcome Trust
actually it is a government funded
organization in part but um the Gates
Foundation putting up money to fund at
home tests because the state is failing
right but it's it's not just
decentralized medicine um you know it is
decentralized media because you know
what for example at least a big chunk of
the centralized media field here you
know Technic journals build and I call
it centralized by the way in the sense
that's culturally centralized
you know it's 10 or 20 different outlets
they all work at each other's kind of
things and all on the same social
network right so simple as medicine
juice in fluid media this is this virus
crisis is going to become a financial
crisis if it isn't already a ton of
money is gonna be printed so you're
gonna need to centralize finance brings
us back to crypto
um you need decentralized preparation
because you're you know city or state is
probably going to say nothing to see
here until suddenly the tsunami descends
upon it right and and that's what I mean
by the decentralized response he is in
you know while I'd prefer a Singapore or
in Israel or an Estonia which is
actually capable of taking care of these
things essentially as a service brighter
you know I hated that government and
they take care of stuff for me in the
same way that you know I don't have to
think about my my you know Dropbox ready
to pay Dropbox if that is not the case
then I still want to be able to do it
myself and that's where did you send
flowers response codes it um does that
make sense yeah I think so and you know
and in this model the blurring of
private and public or private and public
is kind of blurred in a lot of ways
right yeah I mean like one thing I think
a lot about is the reason that I support
you you think you can make a high-level
difference between let's say principled
and pragmatic libertarian leaning people
right the principle libertarians
are against something on a matter of
principle right that is to say even if
let's take a quarantine is actually a
good you know example they are for exit
because it's then the rights individual
or paramount even if it's actually worse
for society and the individual right and
I don't mean worse in the theoretical
way I mean worse than that like died of
a contagious virus kind of way right um
a pragmatic libertarian
though is basically someone who's like
okay some time but um and you know we
should support the policies that
maximize that utility for example to
port in general has fairly free markets
they're fairly profane but they don't
hesitate to kind of step in and put a
thumb on the scale if necessary just for
example they they actually did put price
controls on top of masks and they issued
a bunch of free masks to do
this crisis right and an Tygart much at
least personally I put myself in that
second camp of the pragmatic because the
goal is human flourishing and that
doesn't mean being rigidly ideological
you might be right do you think you know
with something like you know putting
price controls on you know it could be
it could be breather masks it could be a
hand sanitizer it could be any number of
things does that actually work in
America I mean on on a level of
pragmatics so let's let's see there's
kind of three levels of doing something
right let's take me to press controls
level one is like they're really dumb
whole let's put price controls because
we hate these corporations I'm trying to
chip people and so on level two is the
smart version which is actually um if
you impose price controls is going to
cause shortages and that's gonna you
know be a problem because these
manufacturers you know in a time of huge
demand go and have the Capitals go and
purchase more right level three is for
the maintenance of social stability in a
panicky time we will do something like
impose price controls but also otherwise
subsidize manufacturers on the back end
to go and purchase more masks so talk to
senses yeah no III and when I say I
understand I don't necessarily agree but
I'm interested in kind of fleshing out
this you know this picture of how
government and other parts of society
work in in a crisis situation a bunch of
you mentioned before a second second and
third-order health effects and kind of
things that will show up down the line a
bit right now Donald the Trump
administration in Congress I think you
alluded to it before we're gonna see
some kind of massive stimulus project
here in order to to hopefully quiet the
markets or to make people think that
everything's not going down the drain
what are the types of stimulus projects
if you think they should be there should
be what are the types of things that you
think would work and what do you think
are going to be counterproductive so let
me see
you know to extend I think it's a rock
partying ISM you know you said like war
is the health of the state right no I
think it's actually Randolph born but
okay fine fine
daddy got is from yeah yep okay so um
you know like crisis is to help the
state and in many ways I think you know
you can kind of slot in pandemic as
being an even more severe version of
many of the debates we've had on
terrorism over the last twenty years and
then you know then then crime goes to
like a like less version that each of
those as you go up the scale from crime
to terrorism to pandemic um you start
giving government powers to UM constrain
law-abiding people you know in ways you
know that that normally you wouldn't
agree with right because the threat goes
so high right like pandemic you're
talking about basically putting 11
million people in jail without any
probable cause you know there's pus
arrests right um so you know the treaty
part about this cures I'm not saying
that all the you know ethical answers or
what have you but in late January as
wrestling with this because frankly
while I thought you know I'd certainly
known you know pandemic was a
possibility you know this is kind of
like sci-fi territory you know this is
something which I would considered a you
describe the current scenario to mean
back in November I said look you know
what yes that's a challenge to the
theory of exit as prime but why don't
you cross that bridge when we come to it
right now that bridge is being crossed
so we have to come to order the
philosophical issues at play right so
here's a few things I would say first is
um you know ben-gurion had a really good
mental framework um before Israel became
independent there's a time when um you
know there's a white paper that the
British at issue that he disagreed with
and it essentially opposed you know
independence of Israel and what happened
but at the same time they were allied
with the British to fight the Nazis so
he had one line where he said we shall
fight the white paper is if there is no
war we shall fight the Boers if there's
no white dick okay meaning that while
they would argue fiercely against the
white paper they wouldn't undermine the
British in their fight against the Nazis
um and while they would Ally with the
British against Nazis they would not
give up their aspirations for
independence at some point right make
sense he knows recognize these two goals
work in a sense successfully achieved
because maybe Nazis aim they got it
right
you know like over time it took a few
years but it worked right so so that's
kind of how I think about this um you
know from from the utilitarian
standpoint there's no point in freedom
if you're dead in the sense of I
understand live for your guy but and I
agree with it in many ways but died 51
line on it but you know like just
randomly dying from a virus that you
could prevent for some sacrifice of
freedom for a little bit of time does
not seem to me to be a good trade-off
from utilitarian right you know one of
the other kind of questions about a lot
of the stuff is you know Robert Higgs
the economic historian I read a book
called crisis and Leviathan talking
about how you know and it's very much in
in the ballpark that we're talking about
here that the state looks at a crisis it
it it asserts certain types of power it
flexes out when the crisis has passed
you know the power doesn't go away it
states some part of it or all of it so
how do you guard against that because
and we have been seeing you know whether
in terms of economics whether in terms
of certainly surveillance and certain
types of national security things for
all of this 21st century Affleck's by
government how do whatever is coming
down line how do we make sure that the
government gives back most of the power
that it that have built up in itself so
this is actually something like this I
feel that I got it right I mean we'll
see but I think I got it right early on
because it reminded me a lot of post
9/11 period SOTA treated on February 3rd
was um you know like sometimes the
solution creates the next problem my
rough forecast in the future the chrome
virus results in quarantine nationalism
centralization and this may actually
work to stop the spread but one
summer control states will not see their
powers so we decentralize right and so
my answer is I'm not sure you can work
within the system to take away powers
once they've been granted I also don't
think that you should undermine you know
like quarantines that you know could you
know go to the spread of deadly virus to
lots of people because then your
surrounding everybody right however to
reconcile it was two incompatible things
just like ben-gurion and the white paper
were I think the answer is we make the
hard choice to work with the quarantines
and so on in the present day sacrifice
some freedom in order to you know like
quell the virus then we work on
decentralized technologies like
decentralized medicine and other kinds
of things to enable people to prepare in
the future more easily especially if
they're in regions where the government
is incoherent well that's uh let's get
to that what the decentralization will
look like in a second because I that I'm
actually more interested in because you
know the crisis is upon us and things
are gonna happen but when we talk about
quarantines can we be more specific New
Rochelle New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
here in the state of New York has
created a containment area of about a
mile square of mile radius in is certain
but whatever diameter in New Rochelle
New York it doesn't mean that people
aren't allowed to leave their house it
doesn't mean that they can't go to
grocery stores and etc but the National
Guard is there to bring food to people
who can't get out otherwise to clean up
stuff etc when we're talking about
quarantines in America what are we
talking about and what is accept what's
an acceptable quarantine you know
currently or and how does that change so
so the containment zone is basically
like okay on a 1 to 10 scale I give it
okay I guess to because at least its
direction the zone of okay we need to do
something to contain this thing right
however there's many problems with it
first is it's pre announced by two days
so it's like you know like that's
exactly what happened with Luhan all
these people fled
fled but it's also that's understandable
to right and particularly an
authoritarian regime people in Wuhan
knew what was coming and they're like
I'm getting the [ __ ] out of here because
if I if I present to the government you
know I don't know if I'll ever come back
and you know these is something where
like this is it is essentially here's
one way of thinking about it um this is
like a wartime scenario in the sense of
you know you if you talk about like the
anarchists menorca's division right
you're not even are kissed it's like
okay
the state has legitimate powers in terms
of crime and punishment right if you
think about this it's kind of like the
world is being invaded by a virus right
not by the Germans or the Russian rora
but had the by a virus and it non
complying with regulations as no budget
it's completely centralized and
subjected this to kill you and to spread
you don't write it it's committing
murder all the time and and so in those
cases like you know if you're fighting a
war you unfortunately like somebody has
to meet greatest good for the greatest
number decisions does you know and
there's sometimes those are zero-sum
decisions one person does have a
downside in order to have an upside or
vice versa right and in the case of Lu
Han for example I absolutely understand
why somebody from there wanted to flee
it was in their interest if they weren't
sick to get out sentence quarantine zone
verse they might get sicker you know if
they were help well their hand you also
understand why the people outsides not
want people from Yolanda flee because
they didn't want that you know signals
come to them so that unfortunately it's
just a diagonally dis aligned kind of
thing right women from one is a loss for
the other and vice versa there's no
obvious win-win there other than maybe
some compensation for people in the
quarantine zone which is what Iceland
was doing by a point right um and that
might be a smart thing to do by the way
you know you give some Social Credit
some payback it's not fully compensatory
that may be partially so you know things
descending on us so quickly that people
have been fought through things like
that but you know one thing also Creon
by the way some people will quote that
you know quote like those who go up some
freedom for a little security deserve
neither other and that's also I don't
think it's pragmatic in the sense of you
know the
counterargument another American quotas
you know freedom isn't free brag run
meaning that some sacrifice is required
and you know that I think that is also
true you know it doesn't you don't you
don't build a society that some things
like let's come back to your original
point though so you're talking about um
how should we think about mandatory
quarantines right I think you know and
especially let's taking your rachelle
example I think America is managing to
do things in the worst way oh really
okay here's why because the containment
zone is not a quarantine it gets people
to flee its pre-announced on it is so if
you're doing it you do it you know like
run actually quarantine place and you
stop people from leaving it's not an
optional thing if you if you announce it
then people think oh it might become
mandatory let me get out before that
happens and you actually accelerate the
distribution of the virus it's like
bursting spores you push them out right
so that's actually like the worst of the
three options don't do it do it or pre
announce it and then do it that third
one is actually limited spreads the most
so what I mean are you would you
recommend or how do you recommend and
it's interesting to talk to somebody who
was you know seriously you know in line
to be the FDA Commissioner where you
know and we can talk about you know the
way in which the FDA and the CDC and
whatnot are either doing well or bad but
like would you go to you know where
would you say okay we're having a
mandatory quarantine or is it everywhere
in the country I mean the Lombardy
region of Italy you know the industrial
powerhouse of Italy is under a form of
quarantine I mean are we telling people
knots yeah okay so so do we say nobody's
leaving the country nobody's coming in
or if they're coming in they have to be
you know quarantined for a couple weeks
before they're allowed to go to their
final destination I mean I think that's
probably what's gonna happen because
basically you know something that was a
preventable thing we've had a cascading
failure where basically we're flying
blind
thanks to the CBC's case definitions
thanks to the FDA CDRH division in
heating emergency news authorizations
from his labs and bottlenecking testing
during a critical period in February
thanks to all of that basically
everybody was and his still it is in
some ways in a sense of kind of
complacency they thought you know oh
it's being contained you know Trump's
between you know it's only so many
pieces actually it's probably more like
10,000 plus cases you know and the
reason I get that estimate is when when
trevor Bedford prophet UW finally able
to get some sequence data out of these
viruses to viral strains give them the
estimate that in Washington alone
there's large look there's likely an
outbreak of science 570 it was like a
week ago right so so you know it almost
certainly there's like 10 10,000 plus in
the US and we're gonna we're not final
and so what I think is going to happen
is we've traded the de facto decision by
the FDA and CDC to the FDA in particular
it's not include Diagnostics has meant
that our indicator is going to be deaths
right and and hospitalizations we're
going to only take this seriously
once we basically disabled our early
warning system and so we're only going
to take it seriously when just a bunch
of people start piling up in emergency
rooms which is happening by the way in
Washington and California when will we
know that when when will we know that
the you know that the infection is
peaked well no that is Pete when we have
massive diagnostic capability and I'm
talking like hundreds of thousands of
millions of tests a day right there is
an infectious disease right so testing
somebody once is not sufficient you may
need to retest them multiple times so we
need an absolutely massive Diagnostics
effort number one and because you know
the thing is it's not how many pieces
you have it's how many cases you have
and how many tests ear and determine
that if you can run a lot of tests then
you're like the person looking for the
quarter under the lamppost right so
we'll only know it's peaked if we have
massive diagnostic testing capability
we're tracking new cases per day really
rigorously
country and then we're seeing that Pew
come down okay and you don't see in I I
mean it's kind of fascinating to talk to
a you know kind of profit of
decentralization and we're effectively
doing a decentralized response in the
u.s. because different states different
localities are doing all sorts of things
the federal government is largely you
know it I mean it's only getting its act
together now the private sector the
nonprofit sector is doing stuff but you
I mean basically that you know that's a
big mistake for this particular
situation yeah but it is significantly
worse than a competent centralized army
we don't and when we're thinking about
it is if you bucket this into the
national security category you know this
is that's that's a you know min artist
would agree this would fall into serve
it's something that's like an invasion
of the country by admirers okay and you
know so what I think is gonna happen
where let's say what I think is possible
okay just given what's happening other
places given us up in New York I think
it's possible that blue cities get
quarantined by red troops
hmm okay that should end well right you
know that's that that's what we're on
track for unfortunately so this is the
full Omega man scenario right if I was
you know the 1971 Charlton Heston movie
where a some kind of chemical bomb the
Greeks mayhem and turns turns people
into hippies actually albino hippies and
Charlton Heston is one of the last
regular people left but your people are
put under lockdown its martial law you
can be shot if you are seen wandering
around the streets after a certain point
I mean that's essentially what you think
is the response that is necessary the
issue is I don't think that America is
capable of properly calibrating the
response okay so it's either apathy or
it's gonna be this incredible
bureaucratic overreaction rich is going
to be essentially an internal NTS
yeah let's talk a little bit about this
the the ways in which the coronavirus is
forcing us or may force us to rethink
things or if we're smart about it well
actually come up with new ways of doing
things you talked recently in a tweet
about how TSA you know I mean you're
saying we're gonna we're gonna be going
through an internal TSA for the entire
country you talked about how how
actually the way TSA screens things now
is exactly the wrong way to do things
can you expand a little bit about that
yes well first of all it's not hygiene
you know they are basically I don't know
if you've seen these of course you've
seen them but at airports the
checkpoints where you've got the
conveyor belts these buckets that you
put stuff in they're filthy
good running put their shoes in them
it's awful right yeah so it's a salad
bowl yeah to mix together to make sure
like if you didn't have something you
know if you if you come in clean by the
end of when you're picking up your shoes
you're dirty as hell
that's like SFO streets or not the naive
yeah I flew out of there like two days
ago or a week ago so thank you for
getting exactly what I think
you couldn't replace good um you know
especially these three TSA agents have
come up you know positive for the box
and probably patting people down at San
Jose I think you just abolish I mean in
an intelligent country in a competent
country if you felt that you still had
to screen for things okay because yeah
it is possible someone gives a gun or a
knife on a plane I probably as a
consumer want some form of screening for
that during that terrorism is a real
thing um first to Josh wolf Americo
tweeted about it it's basically like
non-invasive scanning I was detect
whether or not you have the guns or
whatever I mean the imaging is there for
that and then no agents no one touches
you or whatever and you can use thermal
cameras and potentially other kinds of
sensing determined does someone have a
feed
that's what they're doing in China um
now like will the u.s. actually do that
I'm skeptical maybe maybe like smart
regions but I don't know can we talk
about other areas you know you you have
talked over the years about kind of
decentralization of things like the
workplace and why not or the workforce
are there ways in which you know and I I
don't want to be as ridiculous as kind
of making lemons out of you know a
pandemic virus or something like that
but you know people are being told okay
if you can work from home you know
disperse yourselves kind of reliably sir
how are what are what are some of the
positive ways that we can take this
moment to think about redoing you know
certain kinds of social economic
political organization that we take for
granted that it probably is not
particularly efficient or useful for
this point in time anyway that's a good
question so I think one analogy would
sort of be you know in world war two
women went to work and then after and
they went to work as a wartime measure
but afterwards it was a new normal right
and women we're now in the workforce and
it was just a different different thing
right you know and by analogy I think
you know one of my friends is something
like 20 20 is the year the future
historians will write the internet
actually begin but ever like this
century actually began because we're
basically in a chaotic way we're doing
like a netiquette about this like a
digital Dunkirk evacuation right retreat
to the cloud to escape the lightning
offensive of the virus you know you're
like retrieves a cloud um and and the
thing about that is return the cloud
into like the primary place we are
conducting work and other kinds of
things there's a whole new argument for
using you know internet technology that
argument is hygiene all right the remote
argument for hygiene I mean that that
that ship something that was happening
already it's something that is the
default way to do it like by default for
example you want on touchless faucets
right by default you want remote capable
jobs by default people want autonomous
taxis and so on and so forth because
it's more hygienic
and this stuff is already happening but
that adds like 20 or 30 points of
population support for it so it's going
to accelerate a ton of things like that
that is a silver lining for this yeah I
love the idea of a digital Dunkirk I
think that really gets at a lot of
what's going on and also what might be
might actually be truly useful and and
kind of path-breaking going forward can
you talk a bit about the code is there a
generational element to all of this I
mean and and there is clearly in the
sense that if you're over 70 you are
much more likely to die you know the
baby boom generation and I guess the
last remnant of the quiet or the Silent
Generation I mean they're being pushed
off this stage this seems to in a weird
way be kind of accelerating that in
terms of kind of cultural economic
political power were almost certainly
witness I would like to believe that
we're witnessing the last presidential
election where it's all about you know
various people who are close to 80 years
old but what you know is there a
generational thing going or how does the
generational split which seems to be
growing significantly in America you
know on a daily basis how is that
influencing or intersecting with the
coronavirus well so it's certainly I
mean one thing that's definitely the
case is all of these politicians are in
the maximum danger area for the
coronavirus and yet they're still
shaking hands or still at rallies and
whatnot it's actually mind blowing to me
I know you know I I don't even
understand it so well and they can't not
do it right because if they don't do it
then they look weak and that they're
about to die if they do do it you know
they might get infected and actually die
so I guess the PISA yeah certainly I
think a way to phrase this in terms of
leadership and maybe you start holding
digital rallies and do periscopes stuff
like that you know you can actually it's
actually easier to hold a larger crowd
guess what you know they can all just
connect live you don't need a venue you
did you can just hold it every single
day you have a sore alley with a million
people right um so I think what's going
to
happiness things that were previously
fully offline like rallies conferences
k-12 education health care stuff that's
resistant the internet into I use
digital competent you know online
education telemedicine all of those
kinds of things the areas of you know
like for example promote legislation
that's gonna come right all these areas
that have previously proved resistant to
the Internet are now just getting booked
looted from the ground and pulled into
the cloud and people are going to be
forced to operate that way for a while
and you know that has some salutary I
mean in the short term that's chaotic
it's gonna cause a lot of dislocation
and so on he does have Sally Tori
long-term benefits because we basically
learn how to modernize certain areas
that approve assistance that over years
alright I think we're going to leave it
there that's a good note to end on we've
been talking with apologies here
navasana
about the corona virus and how do we get
past a you know how do we we live in a
borderless world with a borderless virus
so yep I think that will come back
alright I hope so thanks very much
thanks